das ist heiß begehrt dass neun euro
ticket quer durch deutschland zum
schnäppchenpreis doch natürlich wie soll
es auch anders sein gibt es da auch
einige typen
millionen ansturm auf das 9 euro ticket
der vorverkauf für das begehrte
nahverkehrsticket beginnt für einen
monat zum fast geschenkt preis durch
deutschland fahren allein in berlin
35.000 tickets im vorverkauf dazu kommen
rund
870.000 abokunden dass neun euro ticket
wird zum kassenschlager
ein schnäppchen ohne tücken leider nein
denn es lauern extrakosten so zum
beispiel für fahrräder wer seinen
geliebten drahtesel mit in die bahn
nimmt zahlt drauf für ganz berlin kostet
das monatsticket für die fahrradmitnahme
14 eur 50 und damit mehr als das neun
euro ticket für den besitzer auch
hundebesitzer müssen tiefer in die
tasche greifen kurios die tierbesitzer
selbst fahren günstiger durch
deutschland als ihre lieben vierbeiner
hunde fahren weder kostenlos noch kann
für sie ein eigenes 9 euro ticket gelöst
werden je nach tarif verbund und der
größe des hundes muss ein extra kinder
tagesticket oder gar ein reguläres tages
ticket gelöst werden das neun euro
ticket ein echtes schnäppchen mit
einigen ausnahmen
[Musik]
so darüber und über vieles mehr sprechen
wir jetzt mit fdp-generalsekretär bijan
djir sarai schön gut morgen schön dass
sie hier bei uns sind wird morgen für
die einladung haben sie sich schon neun
eure tickets besorgt nein habe ich nicht
besorgt haben sie vor sich einst zu
ziehen und eine reise anzutreten oder
vielleicht auch nur einen kleinen
dienstweg naja dass das wird man in den
nächsten tagen sehen aber fakt ist und
das hat ihr bericht ja gerade auch
gezeigt das ist ein angebot gewesen das
ist ein angebot ein teil des
entlastungspaket s2 und
offensichtlich wird das sehr gut
angenommen
über details müsste man noch mal
vielleicht mit mit expertinnen experten
reden aber mein eindruck ist dass dieses
angebot dieses entlastungsangebot sehr
gut angenommen wird und das ist positiv
die behörden bürger sollen ja auch
entlastet werden durch das billigere
tanken 30 cent pro liter soll die
entlastung seien heute an den tanksäulen
jetzt aber noch kein unterschied wie
kommt s schauen sie mal wichtig ist die
grundlegende grundsätzliche überlegung
die dahintersteckt wir haben als was wir
also die bundesregierung hat zwei
entlastungs paket verabschiedet und die
bundesregierung und das waren die
überlegung die im koalitionsausschuss
dominiert haben die feste überzeugen
überzeugung dass man in dieser
schwierigen situation gerade auch folgen
des krieges und die auswirkungen auf die
energiepreise sowohl für die unternehmen
als auch für die haushalte dass man sehr
konkret hingeht und die menschen in
deutschland nicht alleine lässt mit
diesen entwicklungen sondern reagiert
auf die veränderten rahmenbedingungen
und das ist genau passiert zwei
entlastungspaket die sehr sinnvoll sind
und die entlastungsmaßnahmen sind
konkret ich habe mir auch übrigens auch
jenen der sendung auch mal erklären
müssen wie die kritiken sind aber
letztendlich sind es entlastung so
sinnvolle maßnahmen die übrigens auch
gut angenommen werden und ich glaube
dass
wir dann diese zeit auch nutzen können
die sind ja diese maßnahmen worüber wir
reden sind alle natürlich befristet aber
im kern ist das eine notwendigkeit und
eine reaktion auf die veränderte lage
die wm land habe aber beim tanken muss
das ja dann auch spürbar seien an der
zapfsäule und wo ist dann spürbar
wirklich für die verbraucher für die
menschen die das wird ja kommen dass
dieser diese auswirkungen werden ja
erkennbar sein also es ist ja sind ja
nicht nur statische preise worüber wir
reden sondern da ist auch eine gewisse
dynamik drin also diese veränderung
werden kommen und die wird man auch im
portemonnaie spüren
gutes versprechen
ja und es gibt einen streit im kabinett
die verteidigungsminister in lambrecht
und zwischen der fertigungs ministerin
lambrecht und der kabinettskollegin
nancy faeser vorabbericht hat nämlich im
interview über vehs zukunft als
innenministerin in berlin gesagt ich
setze darauf dass nancy faeser nicht nur
spitzenkandidatin wird sondern auch die
erste ministerpräsidentin in hessen was
war das denn eine missglückte bewerbung
ein ablenkungsmanöver
kann ich nicht bewerten sie sehen ja das
sind auch interne debatten die sich sehr
auch auf die spd als partei beziehen
deswegen
können wir oder kann ich auch jetzt
nicht zu sagen
beide ministerinnen gehören ja der spd
an sind nicht bei uns schauen sie mal
wie ihr ja nicht so mitbekommen ja
selbstverständlich
wichtig ist der punkt
wir haben krieg in europa und es gibt
zwei ministerien zwei häuser die gerade
in dieser situation außerordentlich
wichtig sind außenministerium und
verteidigungsministerium und beide
häuser müssen gut funktionieren und gut
stehen deswegen erwarte ich auch dass
dieses drumherum diese ganzen
nebenschauplätze auch zusammenhang mit
der ministerin
bald aufhören und man sich auch in der
bundesregierung voll auf diese themen
fokussieren und konzentrieren kann also
ist freiland recht für sie nicht mehr
haltbar das aufhören soll und das habe
ich überhaupt nicht gesagt das gegenteil
also ich würde ich das ist ja auch nicht
es ist ja auch nicht unsere baustelle
als fdp sie haben es ja vorhin gesagt
wir reden über eine spd-ministerin das
müsste die spd bewerten das müsste der
bundeskanzler bewerten mir ist nur
wichtig dass gerade auch vor dem
hintergrund des krieges in der ukraine
dass die linie die handschrift und die
konzentrierte arbeit des
verteidigungsministeriums erkennbar ist
das ist wichtig und deswegen hoffe ich
auch dass
diese
nebenschauplätze um die ministerin herum
dass die bald beendet sind und dass sie
sich auch auf ihre arbeit konzentrieren
kann ja die arbeit unter anderem jahr
auch der ukraine kritik erwartet seit
knapp einem monat auf die
waffenlieferungen aus deutschland muss
scholz jetzt reagieren
wir sollten alle uns darüber im klaren
sein dass dieser krieg sich gerade in
einer entscheidenden phase befindet die
zeit spielt gerade eine große rolle die
ukraine brauchten dringend unsere
unterstützung
und dementsprechend muss auch alles
dafür getan werden damit diese hilfe
auch rasch folgen kann das ist
unheimlich
wichtig und es wäre außerordentlich
ärgerlich also außerordentlich
problematisch aus meiner sicht wenn wir
in so einer entscheidenden situation
nicht in der lage wären zielgerecht dann
auch zu unterstützen aber man hat fast
den eindruck der kanzler verlangsamt das
ganz bewusst
den eindruck habe ich nicht allerdings
weiß ich dass gerade in der partei des
bundeskanzlers in der spd aber auch in
der spd bundestagsfraktion
die angst dass deutschland kriegspartei
werden könnte
sehr groß ist und die gegen die die
debatten der letzten wochen verfolgt
haben wissen ja auch dass innerhalb der
koalition unterschiedliche
geschwindigkeiten bei dem thema
existieren wie ist es für sie ihre
partei regiert er mit uns sprechen wir
über die verteidigungsministerin wo man
sich ein bisschen mehr ruhe wünscht
damit sie sich wie sie sagen auf die
arbeit konzentrieren kann und jetzt
sprechen wir von einem kanzler der nicht
so richtig in die pötte kommt wenn es um
konkrete waffenlieferungen kommt geht
und er auch in seiner kommunikation für
viele deutschen schwer lesbar bleibt ja
ihre frage ist eine sehr gute frage
denn das ist einfach das sind einfach
das ist einfach ein entscheidender
moment eine entscheidende phase des
krieges und es ist außerordentlich
ärgerlich wenn man sich nicht voll
konzentrieren kann auf dieses thema
nämlich die unterstützung für der
ukraine und stattdessen ja auch in
dieser sendung über
nebensächlichkeiten
unterhalten muss nebenbei stellt das ist
ärgerlich deswegen hoffe ich und habe
auch die bitte dass die akteure diese
dinge rasch einstellen und beenden damit
man sich voll auf das wesentliche thema
nämlich die unterstützung der ukraine
konzentrieren kann ist das laufen aus
ihrer sicht was wünschen sie sich da sah
ich wünsche uns ich wünsche mir dass man
nach wie vor sehr genau zuhört was die
ukraine für konkrete unterstützung
braucht in dieser situation
und dem entsprechen diese wünsche
erfüllt werden es gibt ja eine ganze
ansätze ganze reihe von überlegungen die
hat übrigens auch in der vergangenheit
gegeben die ich habe ja vorhin die
unterschiedlichen geschwindigkeiten
innerhalb der koalition angesprochen
aber am ende des tages ist man ja
zusammengekommen es gibt ein beschluss
des deutschen bundestages mit blick auf
die lieferung von schweren waffen
dieser antrag ist auch von der größten
opposition unterstützt worden und jetzt
geht es darum einfach diese dinge auch
systematisch umzusetzen schnell
umzusetzen weil die zeit einfach in
dieser sitzung eine außerordentlich
wichtige rolle spielt absolut
vielen dank für dieses gespräch hier am
montagmorgen eben über die aktuelle lage
in der bundesregierung und irgendwie
weil die ukraine krieg keine einfache
situation
fdp-generalsekretär bijan djir sarai
danke für ihren besuch bei uns im studio
vielen dank